MALE SPEAKER: All
right, welcome.
It's my pleasure to
introduce Jerry Kaplan.
He is a serial entrepreneur.
I'm not sure what flavor
of cereal, but some flavor.
And co-founded four Silicon
Valley start-ups, two of which
became publicly
traded companies.
He's also written-- and I
don't quite understand this,
I hope you explain-- a
bestselling nonfiction novel.
JERRY KAPLAN: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Called "Startup: A
Silicon Valley Adventure,"
selected as Business
Week by one of the top
10 business books of the year.
And his latest book, he's
going to talk with us today
about "Humans Need Not Apply:
A Guide to Wealth and Work,
the Age of Artificial
Intelligence."
He's now teaching at Stanford
in Stanford Center for Legal
Informatics, teaches on the
ethics and impact of artificial
intelligence in
computer science.
JERRY KAPLAN: OK, just
so I can calibrate
to the audience, how many
people here are engineers?
Can you raise your hands?
Excellent, OK.
And how many people
on the live stream?
They can't see me
either, I discovered.
They just see the slides.
So the fact that I'm
standing here buck naked
is invisible to all
of those people.
See what you missed?
They're the lucky
ones, that didn't come.
OK, I'm going to talk today
about artificial intelligence.
How many of you
do work that is in
or related to the field of
artificial intelligence?
Excellent.
I hope that I'm going
to give you a new way
to think about that.
Now the common wisdom about
artificial intelligence
is that we're building
increasingly intelligent
machines that are
ultimately going
to surpass human capabilities.
They're going to steal our
jobs and possibly, even
escape human control
and take over the world.
Well, I'm going to
present the case today
that this standard
narrative is both misguided,
and it's counterproductive.
I think that a more appropriate
framing of the field,
which is actually
better supported
by historical events
and current events,
is that artificial
intelligence is simply
a natural extension of
longstanding efforts
to automate tasks.
This dates back to the start
of the Industrial Revolution.
And then I'm going to talk about
the consequences of thinking
in the field in
this different way,
rather than the way that
it's typically done.
So let me start
with this, what is
artificial intelligence really?
Can machines really think?
Now I want to tell
you something.
After a lifetime of
work in this field
and a great deal of
reflection on this question,
my reluctant and disappointing
answer is very simple.
The answer is no.
Or at least, I agree with
Alan Turing in his conclusion
of his 1950 paper where he
propose the Turing test,
he didn't call it
the Turing test.
You guys, how many
people-- everybody's
familiar with the Turing test?
Great.
By the way, if you
read the paper,
it isn't what the public
thinks the Turing test really
is, a test of intelligence.
That's not what he says,
that's not what it's about.
What he said was, I believe the
question, can machines think,
to be too meaningless
to deserve discussion.
That's actually what
he said in the paper.
Now at best, I think, they don't
think the way people think.
And it's little
more than an analogy
to say that they
really think at all.
Because machines are not
people, and there's simply
no persuasive
evidence that machines
are on a path to becoming
generally intelligent sentient
beings, despite what
everybody sees in movies.
Now you might say--
here's my straw engineer--
but wait a minute,
can't they solve
all sorts of complex reasoning
and perception problems?
My answer is, sure.
They can perform tasks that
humans use intelligence
to solve, but that doesn't mean
that the machines themselves
are intelligent.
It only means that
a lot of tasks
that we thought required
general intelligence,
are really subject to
solution by other, more
mechanical means.
Now there's an old joke in AI,
I like that how many of you
heard this, once the
problem is solved,
it's no longer considered AI.
OK?
Remember that?
Well, personally, I no
longer think that's a joke.
And I'm going to take a look
at some of the signature
accomplishments of
artificial intelligence
from this new and
different perspective.
So let's start with chess.
For decades, the
archetypal test of coming
of age of artificial
intelligence
was whether a machine could
ever beat the world's chess
champion.
Now many of you may not have
been engineers at that time,
but I lived through this.
For a long time,
chess was considered
the quintessential demonstration
of human intelligence.
Surely, people thought,
when a computer
could beat the world's
champion at chess,
artificial intelligence
had arrived.
It was the singularity.
Well, it happened in
1997 when IBM's Deep Blue
beat the then world
champion, Garry Kasparov.
And all kinds of ink was
spilled in the media--
they did have ink
back then-- lamenting
the arrival of
superintelligent machines.
There was all kinds
of hand wringing
over what this
accomplishment meant
for the future of humankind.
But the truth is
it meant nothing,
other than that you could do
a lot of clever programming
and use the increased speed
of computers to play chess.
That's all it meant.
Now the techniques
that were used
certainly had application
to other classes' problems,
but it hardly proved to be
the harbinger of the robot
apocalypse that
everybody had expected.
So people said, OK.
OK.
The world didn't end that day,
well, how about this other day?
And they said computers
can play chess, that's
a limited, well defined domain.
But they'll never be
able to drive a car.
OK, that requires a
broad understanding
of the real world, the ability
to make split second judgments
in chaotic circumstances.
And it requires common sense.
Well as you know, this
bulwark of human supremacy
was breached in
2004, notably in 2004
with the DARPA Grand Challenge
that Sebastian Thrun, you guys
probably know Sebastian was
in charge of that project.
But our self-driving
cars do just that.
They drive cars.
They don't build houses.
Don't cook meals.
They don't make beds.
They drive cars.
So now, we speak of
autonomous vehicles,
but here's the problem.
What that means to an engineer
is very different than what
it means to the general public.
These are two different things.
The public discourse
is dangerously
disconnected from the academic
or technical discourse.
To an engineer, it means
the data from sensors
can be synthesized and
analyzed to formulate
control instructions that
are sent to effectors
like brakes and steering.
But to your mother,
to the general public,
it means that the car
is looking around.
It's figuring out
what it's seeing.
It's understanding,
and then it's
deciding what it's
going to do next.
Now these two descriptions
are fundamentally different.
Anybody here know
Brad Templeton?
No?
OK.
He used to work here on
the Google car project.
He's at Singularity University.
So he had a great quote.
He said, your car will
truly be autonomous
when you instruct it to
take you to the office,
but it decides to go
to the beach instead.
OK, so computers can play chess,
and computers can drive cars
But they moved the
goalpost again.
They could never play Jeopardy.
That requires too much world
knowledge, understanding
metaphors, and clever wordplay.
Well thanks again to the
ingenious people at IBM,
this hurdle has also been
cleared, as you know.
IBM's Watson system beat Ken
Jennings, the world's champion.
That was 2011.
Now what is Watson?
The reality is, it's a
collection of facts and figures
that are encoded into
cleverly organized modules
they can quickly and
accurately answer various types
of common jeopardy questions.
Watson's main advantage,
most people don't know,
was that it could ring in
before the other contestants
when it thought it
had a high probability
of a correct answer.
Don't fight with
a machine that can
hit a button in a millisecond.
Now it's a remarkable
and very sophisticated
knowledge base retrieval
and inference system.
And it was honed-- at
least at that time--
to a very particular
problem set,
and now they're trying to
apply it to other problem sets.
But I'm going to take a
little aside in my talk
and rant here for a minute.
There are some issues that
Watson, as it was presented,
raises the really disturbed me.
More than you may think,
Watson's Jeopardy victory
was something of a magic show.
In my opinion, there
is way too much
of this sort of gratuitous
anthropomorphism
in artificial intelligence.
IBM didn't do the field
any favors, in my view,
by wrapping Watson
in a theatrical suite
of anthropomorphic features.
There's no technical
reason to have
the system say it's responses in
a calm, didactic tone of voice
and have this head-like
swirling graphics, suggesting
that the machine has a
mind and that it's thinking
about problem,
much less to set it
right next to the two
other players that way,
if you've seen how they do that.
These are really
incidental adornments
to what is otherwise
a tremendous technical
achievement.
But without a deep understanding
of how these systems work,
and with humans as the only
available exemplars with which
to interpret the
results, the temptation
for the average person to view
these systems as human-like
is absolutely irresistible.
But they are not.
Robots don't have independent
goals and desires.
A robot that is designed
to wash and fold laundry
may be plenty sophisticated.
It might learn not to
put the laundry away
when you're sleeping
or determine how
you like your shirts folded.
It could be very sophisticated.
But it isn't going to wake up
one day and say, oh my god,
what a fool I've been!
I really want to play the
great concert halls of Vienna.
Not going to happen.
So just as we can teach
bears to ride bikes,
and we can teach chimps
to use sign language,
we can build machines that
perform tasks somewhat
the way people do.
And we can even
simulate human emotions.
We can make them say, ouch,
when you pinch them or wag
their tails when you pet them.
But there's simply
no compelling reason
to believe that this bears
any meaningful relationship
to human behavior or experience.
Machines aren't
people, even if we
build them to talk, and to walk,
and to chew gum like we do.
OK, let me get
back-- end of rant--
let me get back to my examples.
Who's doing machine
learning here?
[INAUDIBLE] is.
OK, good.
So maybe Watson isn't the holy
grail, but what about machine
learning systems?
Aren't they more like
human intelligence?
The answer is not really.
In reality, the use of
these anthropomorphic terms
like deep learning
and neural networks
is really little more than
an analogy, in the same sense
that airplane wings
were inspired by birds.
Consider how machines
and people learn.
You can teach a computer
to recognize cats
by showing it a million images,
as Andrew [INAUDIBLE] did.
Do you guys know Andrew?
Good.
OK.
I gave him this talk by the way.
I don't know how happy he
was to hear my point of view.
You can do this by showing
the machine a million images
of cats, or you could
simply point one out
to a three-year-old and get
same job done That's a cat.
And now they know what a cat is.
Obviously, humans and machines
do not learn the same way.
I'm going to give
you another example.
Anybody here working
on machine translation?
Nobody?
Oh my god.
OK.
Tremendous strides have
been made in this field,
as you probably know,
in the past few years,
mainly by applying statistical
machine learning techniques
to very large bodies
of concorded text.
But how do people perform
this difficult task?
They learn two or
more languages,
along with the respective
cultures and conventions.
And then they read some
text in one language,
they understand what
it says, and then
they render the meaning
as closely as they
can in the other language.
But machine translation, as
successful as it is today,
bears almost no relationship to
the human translation process.
It simply means
there's another way
to approximate the same
results using a machine.
Well, now we carry
around a smartphone.
It's sort of reminiscent
of the capabilities
of the computer on the
Star Trek's Enterprise,
or maybe even the
Hal 9000, hopefully
minus the homicidal intent.
What is it?
Google-- What was the term?
Hey Google Voice?
AUDIENCE: OK Google.
JERRY KAPLAN: OK Google.
OK Google.
Sorry.
Yeah, you can talk to your
phone, and it talks back.
And it becomes more
capable every day
as you download new apps and you
upgrade the operating system.
But do you really think of
your phone as getting smarter,
in this human sense,
when you download an app?
Or you enable the
voice recognition?
Certainly not in the
same sense that you
get smarter when
you learn calculus
or you learn philosophy.
It's the electronic equivalent
of a Swiss army knife.
It's a bunch of different
information processing
tools bound together
into a single unit,
to take advantage of
some commonalities,
like detailed maps or
like internet access.
You have one integrated mind.
Your phone has no mind at all.
No one's home.
OK, so what is intelligence?
Let me go on to this.
So machines perform an
increasingly diverse array
tasks that people
perform by applying
their native intelligence.
Does that mean
machines are smart?
Let's look at how we might
measure supposed machine
intelligence.
Now I pulled this
image off the internet.
I did not make this slide.
I'm Illustrating
a point with it.
We can start by looking at how
humans measure intelligence.
And of course, one very
common way is with IQ tests.
But even for humans, this is
an extremely flawed concept.
We love to measure and
rank things with numbers,
but let's face it.
Reducing human intelligence
to a flat, linear scale
is highly questionable.
Little Sally did two more
arithmetic problems than Johnny
in the time that was allotted.
So her IQ is 7 points
higher than his.
Bull.
This is not to say that some
people aren't smarter than
others, only that's simple,
linear numerical measures
provide an inappropriate patina
of objectivity and precision.
Psychologists are
fond of pointing out,
there are many different
kinds of intelligence.
Social, emotional, analytic,
athletic, musical, et cetera.
What does it mean here to say
that Mozart and Einstein have
the same IQ.
Now suppose we gave the
same IQ test to a machine,
the same ones we
administer to humans.
After all, how else are we
going to measure their IQs?
Well it took only
one millisecond
to accurately complete
the same sums that
took Sally and Johnny an hour.
That machine must
be super smart.
Well, as you may know,
calculating-- some people don't
know this, it's a really
cool fact-- calculating
used to be the province of
highly trained specialists,
and they were known
as calculators.
It was a profession.
The profession required
considerable intelligence,
attention to detail, and skill.
Now all it takes is
a $0.99 calculator.
Oh my god, the robots
can out perform us!
They're super smart
on measures that we
use for human intelligence.
What are we going
to do when they
decide they don't
need us anymore,
and they're going to take over?
OK.
You're probably
wondering how I'm going
to tie this slide into my talk.
I'll give it a try.
The truth is that intelligence
isn't an objective, well
defined, measurable attribute
like mass or blood pressure.
It's a subjective,
culturally influenced concept
that's more like beauty.
Who's more attractive?
Angelina Jolie or January Jones?
Is the answer the
same in Nairobi?
Or in Karachi?
Can you say that one is 6.5%
more attractive than the other?
Is that a meaningful
thing to say?
Now let's apply this observation
to the superintelligence
debate, which hopefully,
many of you have heard.
There's a book by Nick Bostrom,
anybody heard of that book?
A couple people?
OK.
I'm going after him
at a talk next week.
It's not going to be good.
Let's apply the same thinking
to the superintelligence debate.
As anybody can see
from the movies-- here
it is-- female
robots are getting
more attractive and more
capable all the time.
If I were to subscribe to a
concept like superintelligence,
I could write a scholarly
tome about how robots
are becoming more beautiful.
And I could, i don't know,
maybe I could call it like,
super attractiveness
or something.
And I could conclude that
this is an existential threat
to humanity.
Because when female robots begin
to exceed human attractiveness,
men will only desire to
mate with them instead
of other people,
and that's going
to disrupt our natural
reproductive process.
OK, that's the same
argument that you
find in super
intelligence, played out
in a different domain.
Now here's a news
flash for you guys,
there's no such thing as
a female or a male robot,
despite the what the
average moviegoer
is encouraged to believe.
And just like there's no
such thing as a generally
intelligent robot.
That's a comparable
slice of fiction.
Now we might want to
create such a thing,
but a sober look at
the results so far
don't suggest at all that
we're on the path to doing so.
It's a little bit
like climbing a tree
and claiming progress
on getting to the moon.
Now there's a long and
undistinguished history
of false alarms in
artificial intelligence,
predicting the imminent
emergence of generally
intelligent machines.
Anybody here know
what a perceptron is?
I took this out of
the talk, but you've
got to be older than-- It's
interesting, gray hairs,
hands go up.
This was the beginning
of neural networks,
very interesting story.
But neuroperceptrons,
you guys may not
have heard of symbolic systems,
general problem solvers,
connection machines-- anybody
remember the connection machine
was going to take over the
world-- scripts, frames, expert
systems-- who lived
through that debacle.
I did.
I was in one of
those companies--
a case based reasoning, Doug
Lennit's work-- it's pysch.
You guys heard of that-- the
fifth generation computers
and Lisp machines, they were
going to take over the world.
Luckily, most of these
have been forgotten.
So are the robots taking over?
Well by the
superintelligence logic,
the machines took
over a long time
ago whether they
were smarter not.
They move our freight.
They score a test.
They explore the cosmos.
They handle our billing.
They plant and pick
most of our crops.
They trade stocks.
They store and
retrieve our documents.
They manufacturer
just about everything,
including themselves.
Sometimes with human
help, sometimes
without human intervention.
All these tasks
that not long ago,
would have been regarded
as requiring human effort
and intelligence.
And yet, they often predicted
demise of human labor,
never ride.
And nor have the
machines taking over.
The robots are
doing these things,
but they're taking
over our businesses.
They're not marrying
our children.
And they're not watching
the SciFi channel
when you're not home.
That's not what's going on.
So what's wrong with the
traditional picture of AI?
We can build machines
and write programs
to perform tasks that previously
required human intelligence
attention.
But there's nothing
really new about that.
Plowing a straight
furrow, used to be
a matter of considerable human
experience and skill, yet
today, no one marvels at
the ability of a tractor
to do the same thing.
More contemporary example,
painting natural looking hair
used to be a skill
honed through years
of practice and apprenticeship
by our most talented artists.
But today, nobody
blinks an eye when
Disney uses CGI rendering to
animate Rapunzel's flowing
hair.
Now both of those
advances are better
understood as progress
in automation,
not as re-creation of
human intelligence.
We can program machines to
solve very complex problems,
and we can program it to
operate with great independence.
But to call this a simulated
form of human intelligence
is little more than a fancy.
So my point is simple, lots of
problems that we think require
intelligence, don't.
There are other
ways to solve them.
And that's what we're
using machines to do.
OK.
Now I hope you can
give me my perspective
just for a few minutes, and let
me talk about what that means
in terms of the social
impact and economic impact
that these things
are going to have.
It's certainly true that
artificial intelligence
is going to have a
serious impact on labor
markets and employment,
but perhaps not in the way
that you expect.
If you think of machines as
becoming evermore intelligent
and threatening our livelihoods,
the obvious solution
is to prevent them
from getting smarter.
To lock our doors and arm
ourselves with tasers.
And you see stuff like this,
even among AI community
we write stop this research
is dangerous these things are
going to get loose.
Well I got news for you,
the robots are coming,
but they aren't exactly
coming for our jobs.
Machines and computers
actually don't perform jobs,
this is misunderstood.
What they do is
they automate tasks.
Except in the most
extreme cases,
you don't roll in a robot
and show an employee here,
to the door.
Instead, the new
technology hollows out,
it changes, the jobs
that people perform.
Now even experts spend most
their time doing mundane,
repetitive tasks like
reviewing lab test results,
drafting contracts, or
writing press releases,
filling out paperwork, ,
forms, things like that.
On the blue collar
side, you've got
lots of workers who drive
cars, load trucks, pack boxes,
take blood samples, fight fires,
deliver mail, direct traffic.
And many of those intellectual
and physical tasks
require straightforward logic
or simple hand-eye coordination.
And the new technologies,
mainly driven by advances in AI,
are poised to automate a
lot of these kinds of tasks.
Now if your job involves
a narrow, well defined set
of duties, as many
do, then indeed,
your employment is at risk.
If you have a broader
set of responsibilities
or if your job requires
some kind of human touch,
such as expressing sympathy
or providing companionship,
I don't think that you really
have much to worry about.
Check out this comparison
of bricklayers, laid bricks.
That's what they do, you can
build a machine to lay bricks.
Licensed practical
nurses-- I got this off
of an official list
of their duties--
ensuring patients
and their families
understand release instructions,
providing emotional support.
Most jobs require a mix
of general capabilities
and specific skills.
And as the machines can perform
more routine activities,
the plain fact is
that fewer people
are needed to get those
particular jobs done.
So one person's
productivity enhancing tool
is another's pink slip.
Or more likely, a job opening
that doesn't need to get
filled.
There's this big, false
debate between whether we're
making people more
productive or whether we're
putting people out of work.
These are potential future
headlines that capture that.
The New York Times,
they might say,
robots steal jobs
at record pace.
And The Wall Street Journal
might look at the same day
and say, profits rise as
worker productivity soars.
OK.
Now economists call this
process of the hollowing
out of these jobs, changing the
jobs, structural unemployment.
Automation, whether it's driven
by artificial intelligence
or not, changes
the skills that are
necessary to perform the work.
If the oncologist
no longer needs
to read MRIs or the
accountant operates a computer
program instead of doing
their calculations,
which they used
to do by hand, you
have different aptitudes,
different talents,
and different training
that might be required.
So this is what they call
structural or technical
unemployment.
It's the mismatch
of skills that are
needed by employers to the
actual skills of the workforce.
So the more pressing
problem posed
by artificial
intelligence for workers
is not so much a lack of jobs
but the way new technology
transforms the nature of work
and therefore, the training
that's required to
perform those jobs.
Now it's helpful to look at
this problem dynamically.
Historically, as
automation has eliminated
the need for workers, the
resulting increasing wealth
has eventually generated
all kinds of new jobs
to take up the slack.
And I see no reason why
this won't continue.
But the keyword
there is eventually.
Let me give you some data.
It's very helpful to
look at this dynamically.
200 years ago, more than
90% of the US population
worked in agriculture.
Basically, almost
all anybody ever
did was grow and prepare food.
The stuff you see
on Downton Abbey,
that was a tiny little
sliver of the population.
Today, less than 2%
of the population
is required to feed everybody.
On my god!
Is everybody out of work?
Of course not.
We've had plenty
of time to adapt.
And as our standard of
living has relentlessly
increased-- which I'm going
to get to in a minute--
new opportunities have
always arisen for people
to fill the ever
expanding expectations
of our ever richer society.
Now try this on for size.
Imagine you are an average
person in the 1800s
and we time-traveled
them to today.
They would think
we'd all gone nuts.
Why not work a few hours a week,
buy a sack of potatoes and jug
of wine, build a
shack in the woods,
dig a hole for an outhouse,
and live a life of leisure.
That's what they would think.
So somehow, however,
our rising expectations
seem to magically keep
pace with our wealth.
So you might say, well, OK,
what's going to happen next?
What are these jobs of tomorrow?
Now contrary to
what you might think
about the end of work or
robots doing everybody's jobs,
it turns out that there
are many, many, current
and there are going to be
a lot more future jobs that
simply can't be automated.
They inherently involve
a personal touch,
or demonstration of skill, or
person to person interaction.
I don't see why we
can't become a society
of competitive gamers, of
artisans, of personal shoppers,
of flower arrangers,
of tennis pros,
of party planners, and no
doubt a lot of other things
that don't exist yet at all.
I mean, nobody wants to go to
a robotic undertaker who says,
I am so sorry for your loss.
It doesn't work.
So who's going to do the
real work, you might ask.
Well our great-grandchildren
may think our idea of real work
is so 21st century.
I won't be around, but
a lot of you guys will.
It may only take 2% of
the Population assisted
by some pretty
remarkable automation,
to accomplish what takes
90% of our labor today.
The jobs you guys
have may not be there.
So what?
That's the historical
pattern and it's
likely to continue
in the future.
Now our expectations
keep rising,
like my mythical 1800s
person out the woods,
today, here's some weird facts.
It's really fun.
It's great we have the internet.
It makes it easy to
pop up crazy stuff.
Today, 70% percent of
the people in the US
take a shower every day.
Now I'm not asking
for a show of hands,
but in 1900 the average
was once a week.
That was the old normal.
Now it may be as important
to our grandchildren
to have fresh flowers
in the house every day,
as it is to us to
shower every day.
That's the kind of
change in expectations
that we're talking about.
Two of my kids just
got their first jobs.
And I couldn't help but notice
that their chosen professions
didn't exist 10 years ago.
One does social media
promotion for restaurants,
and the other
one-- you guys will
know what this is-- works at
Udacity, the online education
company.
So that's the good news.
But there's bad news.
The bad news is it takes
time for these transitions
to happen.
And a new wave of AI
enabled applications
is likely to accelerate the
normal cycle of job destruction
and creation.
So we have to find new ways
to retrain displaced workers.
And we don't have the right
mechanisms to do that today.
So I've written a book.
So in the book, I talk
about what kinds of things
we need to do.
Well, one of them is the idea,
I just call it a job mortgage.
It's not new to me,
there's been a history
of talking about this, but
I framed it a little bit
differently.
Basically, people
should be able to learn
new skills by borrowing against
their future earnings capacity.
Today, vocational
training in the US
is really messed up--
this is all in the book--
mainly because the government
is the lender of first resort
for the student loans.
And the skills of
people learn are
disconnected from the immediate
needs of the marketplace.
So we're not investing
in education,
we're handing out
money to people
to learn things that won't help
them to pay that money back.
If you can't get a job, too bad.
Your student loan is still due.
We need to fix that.
We need to create new
financial instruments
that tie the
deployment of capital
to the return on
investment, just
as we do with home mortgages.
And the history of that is also
in the book, very interesting.
That was created and it doubled
home ownership in the US
by creating special kinds
of financial instruments.
We can use the discipline
of the marketplace
to help us productively
repurpose displaced workers.
And that not only
benefits the ones who
find their skills obsoleted,
like you programmers,
but society in general,
it's good for us.
Now finally, there's
one more dark cloud
related to advances in
artificial intelligence.
While it's true that automation
makes society richer,
there are very serious
questions about whose pockets
are going to be filled
by that increased wealth.
Now those of us
in high tech tend
to believe we're developing
dazzling technologies
for a needy and grateful world.
And indeed, we've made
tremendous progress
on raising the standard of
living for the very poorest
of the poor around the world.
But for the developed world,
the news is not so good.
Many of you may know that up
until around 1970, on and off,
we found ways to
distribute at least some
of these economic benefits
of increased productivity
broadly across society.
And this supported the rise
of this mythical middle class.
But it doesn't
take much to see--
and economists are
lamenting the fact--
that those days are over.
As economists know,
automation is the substitution
of capital for labor.
And I'm here to tell
you, Karl Marx was right.
He was an economist.
The struggle between
capital labor
is a losing proposition
for the workers.
What that means is that
the benefits of automation
naturally accrue to those who
can invest in new systems.
And why not?
People aren't really working
any harder than they used to.
And frankly, we're not really
smarter than people used to be.
In fact, interesting fact,
is that working hours have
actually decreased on
average, slowly, but pretty
consistently, over
the last 100 years,
it used to be normal
to work an 80 hour
week in the early 1800s.
The reason we can
do more with less
is that the business owners
invest some of their capital
into the process and
productivity improvements.
And it makes sense, under
our economic system,
that they get the rewards.
So what does all this
got to do with AI?
Is [INAUDIBLE] on there?
No.
Some of your greatest hits?
All your friends?
The technologies that
are on the drawing boards
and are in the labs
here at Google,
are quickening the hearts of
entrepreneurs, and investors,
and business owners
everywhere because they're
the ones that stand to benefit.
While they're able to
export more and more risks
to the rest of society, and
workers become less secure,
wages stagnate,
pension funds go bust.
We're raising a
generation of contractors
for the gig economy, whose
variable working hours
and health benefits
are their problem.
We need to fix that.
Now some people, if you're
following the latest
political debates,
if you've watched
any of the Republican
debates-- horrifies me--
people have the
mistaken impression
that the free market is going
to address these problems,
if only we can get the
government out of way.
I'm here to tell
you, our economy
is hardly an example
unfettered capitalism.
And believe me, I've been
a beneficiary of that.
The fact is, there are all
sorts of rules and policies
that drive where the capital
goes, how it's deployed,
who gets the returns.
It's out of whack.
And the problem is that
our economic and regulatory
policies have become decoupled
from our social goals.
And we have to fix that.
But how do we do that?
OK.
Now as with the
labor markets, it's
helpful to look at this
problem dynamically.
If you just look
at it today, you
think well, we go
to raise taxes,
take the money away
from the rich people,
give it to poor people.
That's not necessarily the case.
The good news is that
economy isn't static.
It actually doubles, GNP
doubles every 40 years.
And it's done that
pretty reliably
since the start of the
Industrial Revolution
in the 1700s.
Here's some more weird
facts from the internet.
In 1800, can anybody guess
what the average household
annual income was in the US?
1800, average annual
household income of US,
anybody want to venture a guess?
AUDIENCE: $1,000
JERRY KAPLAN: Exactly.
People actually get this
right, the people in the front,
it's interesting.
The ones in the
front get it right.
The ones in the back
row are on their phones,
checking their mail.
It was $1,000 That's an
inflation adjusted figure.
This isn't some kind of old
greenbacks, gold standard,
we're talking about $1,000.
Now that's about
the same as it is
today in Malawi and Mozambique.
And it's probably
not coincidental
that their economies, the
structure of their economies,
look surprisingly
similar to what
it was in the US 200 years ago.
So I doubt that people
in Ben Franklin's time
thought of themselves
as dirt poor,
that they were barely
scratching out an existence.
Now what does this mean?
40 years from now,
most likely, there
will literally be twice as
much wealth to go around.
And the challenge for us
is to implement policies
that are going to
encourage that wealth
to be more broadly distributed.
We don't have to steal from
the rich and give to the poor.
We need to provide proper
incentives for entrepreneurs
and businesses to
find ways to benefit
an ever wider swath
of society, as opposed
to their stockholders
and themselves.
Now in my book-- available
in bookstores everywhere.
I have one back there-- I
give at least one example.
And it's just an
example, the kind
of thinking I believe we should
do to solve this problem.
Let me give you an idea.
I suggest that we make
corporate taxes progressive,
based on how broadly distributed
a company's equity is.
So the more stockholders
a company has-- which
is suitably defined, and I
do so in the book-- the lower
the tax rate that
that company has.
Microsoft, you might not
know, has one of the most
broadly distributed
stockholder bases in the world.
Bechtel?
Anybody know Bechtel?
Heard of Bechtel?
I think it's still owned by one
family, it's a couple people.
It's a huge corporation.
Now, if we do
this, the companies
that have a lower tax
rate have an advantage
in the marketplace.
And believe me, these
people are going
to figure out how to distribute
the wealth more widely in order
to maximize the return
for the corporation.
There's another
talk I can give--
we're going to run out of time
here-- it's very interesting,
but we used to give away assets
in the United States, when
we were an agrarian economy.
In an agrarian economy,
assets were land.
And If you worked the
land for seven years,
you got it for free.
The government
literally gave it away.
Now today, the total
value, by my research
of all the real estate
in the United States,
I think it's 17% of
our assets, mostly we
have financial instruments.
So the idea of
giving away money,
suitably used for
productive purposes,
is not at all
unreasonable and not
without historical precedent.
Thank you.
So I believe that progressive
policies like this
can promote our social
goals without stifling
economic growth.
We just have to get on with
it and stop believing the myth
that unfettered capitalism
is the answer to the world's
problems.
OK.
So let me wrap up.
I don't want you to
think that I'm anti-AI.
Nothing is further
from the truth.
I think its potential impact
on the world is similar--
and I'm not exaggerating-- to
the invention of the wheel,
possibly to the steam engine.
But when you think of
it not of some kind
of magical discontinuity in the
development of intelligent life
on earth, but rather as
a powerful collection
of automation tools
with the potential
to transform our livelihoods and
to vastly increase our wealth.
The challenge we face is that
our existing institutions,
without some
enlightened rethinking,
run a serious risk of making a
mess out of this opportunity.
I'm supremely confident that
our future is very bright, more
Star Trek than Terminator.
But the transition may
be protracted and brutal
unless we pay attention to the
issues that I've raised today.
We have to find
new and better ways
to ensure that our economy
doesn't just motor on,
going faster and
faster while throwing
evermore people overboard
to increase its speed.
Our technology and our
economy should serve us, not
the other way around.
Thank you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Well, thank you very
much for that talk.
I have to, say I agreed with
almost everything you said.
I'm not sure I'm such
a good discusser.
Maybe we should-- Let's
take a question or two
from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned job mortgages,
and the first thing
that comes to my mind
is indentured servitude,
when I think of that.
So how do you draw the line,
necessarily, between the two?
JERRY KAPLAN: Well, the word,
mortgage, little known fact,
comes from French, it
means pay until death.
Mortgage, that's what it means.
I'm serious about that.
The answer of course is
if you take out a loan,
you have to pay it back.
If we simply tie the loan
to your future income
so that we limit it-- And there
is a lot of activity going on
for student loans today, where
the US government has a bunch
programs where you
can defer payments,
depends on how much you make.
Then I think we can do
it without it becoming
indentured servitude as such.
It's just better
than what we've got.
Which is, you work, and
you've got to pay the man,
regardless of whether you
have the income to do it.
MALE SPEAKER: They did do
something like this at Yale
20 or 25 years ago, where
you could take out a loan
and pay back in equity,
so I would pay back
5% of my adjusted gross income,
or you could take out the loan
and pay back a fixed amount.
So you've got a debt
or equity choice.
The trouble is, there was
a serious adverse selection
problem that all the people that
are going to high income jobs
took the debt contract, and all
the people that are going into,
let's say humanities or
less well paying paths
took the equity.
So they were
certainly sharp enough
to recognize a difference.
So it is a little
tricky when you design
these financial contracts.
And for some reason, we made the
student loans non-dischargeable
in bankruptcy for the
same sort of reason.
Because the smart thing to
do would be to graduate,
immediately go bankrupt
because you have no income,
then you remove that obligation
and go out and get a job.
So it's tricky because of people
responding to the incentives
you said in terms of
the financial contract.
JERRY KAPLAN: I agree with that.
The thing to bear
in mind though,
is I think these are
all solvable problems.
They're just issues that need
to be addressed. in some way.
Mortgages, as you probably
know, are non-recourse loans,
and that was the key.
It was tied to property.
Now somebody who
is going to loan
you the money for
your house, now they
care about what
that house is worth.
If it was the other
way around, you
could buy any house you want.
I don't care what it's worth,
we'll loan you the money,
and you're on the hook.
It would be a very
different world.
And there are many
steps in between.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, I
think part of the problem
is that you don't have
the same due diligence
standards for handing out
education loans as you
do for mortgages.
There's a serious
question of whether you're
giving these loans in
cases where they probably
could be forecast,
they wouldn't pay off.
And it's very hard to do
that when they're government
subsidized because
then you're saying,
oh, you're treating these people
different than those people,
and so on.
There was actually just a
piece in either The Wall Street
Journal or The New York
Times in the last week
about that exact
topic, that maybe we
should use more diligence
in awarding the student
loans in the first place.
And of course, that's
the way it used
to be when I was in college.
I got loans from the
University, but the university
knew I was a pretty good bet.
Other questions?
Here, [INAUDIBLE], over here.
AUDIENCE: All right,
thanks for coming.
You were pointing the
finger at the general public
for not understanding
the limitations
of artificial
intelligence, but I'm not
so sure it's just
the general public.
I think this idea
might be unwelcome even
among people who work
in software development,
or work in artificial
intelligence.
My question for you
is, how unpopular
is this message, even
for people who work
in artificial intelligence?
JERRY KAPLAN:
Well, I'm not sure.
I mean, I've only given
the talk or versions
of this a few times.
And usually what happened,
it happened up at Google
in Kirkland, I had about
1/3 of the audience going,
yeah, that's right!
This guy's Donald Trump,
he's telling the truth.
And you know, other people
are just kind of, hmmm.
If somebody comes
in and says, you
are working on the most
important thing in the world.
This is the future of evolution.
You are going to build machines.
We're going to upload our minds.
There's a wonderful book called.
"Apocalyptic AI."
It is fantastic, and
nobody has read it,
by a religious
historian, talking
about the history
of apocalyptic ideas
in Judeo-Christian societies.
And then, he maps
that onto this.
He went to Carnegie Mellon,
he interviewed everybody.
And I mean, I'm arguing against
the soothsayer who promises
eternal life and salvation.
I'm not expecting
to get very far.
And I say, that's nonsense,
you're going to die.
But I think that a sensible
person, particularly
those working in the field, take
a look at what you're doing.
Think about what you're doing.
And do you really feel,
just because there's
some guy telling
you, this is the most
important thing since sliced
bread, do you believe that?
Or is it just dressing up?
And I think it's
just dressing up.
If they hadn't called-- I've had
to take this out of the talk.
The term artificial intelligence
is what caused the problem.
It started in 1958,
by John McCarthy.
Any of you guys
know John McCarthy?
Know who he is at least?
OK.
I did that at Stanford.
Only like 1/3 of the graduate
students in Computer Science
knew who John McCarthy was.
John McCarthy invented the term.
And he did it as a reaction
against Norbert Wiener,
who had cybernetics.
And he didn't want it to
be known as cybernetics,
so he came up with the term.
Now John was an interesting guy.
He was a mathematician,
but he had
the greatest inadvertent
marketing coup in history
by coming up with that term.
It has driven all this media.
All this-- If he had just called
it logic programming, which
is what he meant
by it, by the way,
back then, which has been
discredited as a basis
for artificial intelligence, we
wouldn't be in this room today.
And I wouldn't be
spending my time
trying to promote these ideas.
MALE SPEAKER: So
one thing you said
that I thought
was very important
is this distinction
between jobs and tasks.
And as you know, from
the Department of Labor,
there is this massive listing
of job titles and tasks.
I think your nurses example
was taken from that.
You can look this up online.
And so people have
gone through this.
And people at Oxford
and actually, McKinsey
is going through
it now, and trying
to identify which
tasks are automatable.
Now what happens,
of course, if you're
in a job where there are only
a few automatable tasks, that's
great for you because the
automation compliments
your services.
You can do more of
these other things
and less of these
tedious, unpleasant tasks.
But on the other hand,
if you're in a job where
almost all your
tasks in that job
are automatable, like
the bricklayer example,
in fact, then, of course,
you're not such good shape.
So the challenge is to look
both at the fraction of tasks
or the number of tasks
in your job description
that are automatable.
And that's going to give you a
clue of whether the technology
is going to function as
a complement to your job
or as a substitute for it, So
McKinsey's working on this,
and it'll be out in a few weeks.
JERRY KAPLAN: Yeah.
The McKinsey report sounds
like it's going to be great.
I've seen some summaries of it.
The Frey-Osborne study from
Oxford is terribly flawed.
I actually had dinner
with them two weeks ago.
MALE SPEAKER: I looked at it.
It seemed to me it
was-- Their methodology
wasn't very clearly described.
And I think the
McKinsey guys, I'm
urging them to make
their work reproducible,
so that you could--
There could be
other opinions offered on what
tasks are really automatable.
JERRY KAPLAN: But
the great example
of how science doesn't
proceed scientifically.
Or this debate [INAUDIBLE].
The Oxford study by
Frey-Osborne had a number in it,
in the title.
It said 47% of jobs will be
automatable in the next 20
years.
I mean, they're right or
wrong, that got total play
from Oxford.
So I mean, I have to agree
with Hal completely on this.
It's about task automation.
Now there are two things
that have happened in AI--
I'm not going to
spend a lot of time
on this-- they're
recent advances,
so they really are going
to affect the tasks that
can be automated.
The first of them
is machine learning,
which allows us to
take a certain kind
of perceptual tasks, and
convert that information
into actionable symbolic form.
And the second is
basic robotics of being
able to move things
around, but now
to control that
using the information
that we can get in from censors.
So a great deal of
blue collar tasks
are going to be automatable.
That's what's going to happen.
And a great deal of
intellectual tasks,
like writing dumb
press releases,
are going to be
automatable as well.
So my basic point, which I
didn't really make in the talk
is I think things are
going to accelerate
over the next 20 or
30 years, and it's
going to be a big problem.
I'm not against doing it.
It's great.
Automation is good.
It just has some
negative side effects
and we need to deal with those.
AUDIENCE: So we have
seen prominent academics,
you know, Stephen Hawking,
Elon Musk, Bill Gates,
speak out against
artificial intelligence.
And I think they're
really speaking out,
not against narrow intelligence,
things like Watson,
but really general purpose
learning algorithms.
Things like DeepMind
and Vicarious.
What do you see to be their
greatest argument for being
worried about
artificial intelligence,
and how would you refute it?
JERRY KAPLAN: Well,
the problem is
what you're really
talking about,
is a tweet from Stephen Hawking.
It's just, this is the
problem with the way
science and society proceeds.
He's very prominent.
He's well known.
He puts out a tweet, you can
interpret it in multiple ways.
I was at Oxford, where a
guy actually said to me--
This is worth 15 seconds.
It was worth the trip out there
just because a guy looked me
in the eye and he said to me, I
wasn't going to be able to make
your talk, but my dinner with
Stephen Hawking was cancelled.
That was worth the
trip to England,
to have somebody say that to me.
I mean, my reaction is
great mind, great man.
I'm not going to argue
with him about radiation
from black holes.
I don't think he
should be arguing
with the people who are here,
doing artificial intelligence.
They're hearing it from each
other, it's a big echo chamber.
It's not that they don't
have something to say.
And there is arguments
on the other side.
But it's just-- I heard
somebody say this,
worrying about
superintelligence, worrying
about the threat of
AI, it's like worrying
about overpopulation on Mars.
We're just about maybe going to
be able to get a man on Mars,
despite the film.
And why are we
worrying about this?
It's sucking the oxygen
out of the debates
that we really need to be having
about what's really going on
and what kind of
societal problems
these things are going to
cause in your lifetime.
And we shouldn't be spending
the time and energy on it.
I'm fine with academics
going to conferences
and having talks about this.
But we got to get the, gee wiz,
out of artificial intelligence.
When it starts to
show up, that's great.
MALE SPEAKER: I would
say I differ slightly
because I don't
think it's so much
the artificial
intelligence component,
but there are
technologies that have,
let's say military use or
offensive use, that of course,
will be more broadly available.
Just like mobile phones
are more broadly available,
drones that deliver
bombs will be available.
And so there's
questions, that would
be the threat the most worries
me, of kind of a homemade,
small scale attacks of one sort
or another using technology.
I don't know that
there's a lot we
can do about that,
except build better
defenses against such things.
But I think that is a concern.
Technology makes
people more powerful,
and the people it
makes more powerful
may be good guys or bad guys.
So it's going to escalate.
JERRY KAPLAN: Yeah.
You know Stewart Russell?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
JERRY KAPLAN: Now, I don't
always agree with him,
but at least he's trying.
[INAUDIBLE] point of view.
And this goes back
to your question.
If what you mean
by AI is dangerous,
is that robots are going to
become sentient and take over
the world, forget it.
Not relevant at all.
But that's not to say that
technology cannot be dangerous
and represent real
threats to real people.
And this is very scary because
what's happening-- and Stewart,
I think when he's
giving in depth talks
rather than saying the robots
are coming-- what he talks
about is that the price of the--
The access and price of some
of these technologies that can
have mass destructive power,
it used to be, or is now,
confined to very big, hopefully
responsible, players
like the United States.
But that may not be
the case in 10 years.
You know, you could
build little drones
that will run around, you know,
recognize people, and inject
some poison in their eye
when they're sleeping.
I mean, that's the kind of
crazy stuff that can happen.
And if some despot
or crazy whack
terrorist types get a
hold of that technology,
it could be very dangerous.
So there's a huge
debate going on.
MALE SPEAKER: If you can
deliver a pizza by drones,
you can deliver bombs by drones.
JERRY KAPLAN: Exactly.
That's exactly right.
And there's a very big debate
going on inside the military.
And at the UN there's a
sanding counsel on this.
And a lot of philosophers
and technology experts.
That sort of-- They're really
trying to grapple with this.
But it's like the
biotechnology thing,
I would use that as an analogy.
It's very dangerous.
Much more dangerous
than the AI stuff.
You guys have probably
heard of CRISPR, Cas9 stuff?
I mean, they're trying
to deal with that.
What are the ethics of this?
What's OK to do?
How much development?
What kind of labs do we need?
We'll have to do the same thing
in artificial intelligence.
AUDIENCE: So I guess the
first thing is that I never
really understood
why people always
treat technological advancement
that improves productivity
as something that
threatens jobs.
Because if someone can
produce more of something
in the same time, it
basically could also
mean that we can all have
more of that same thing,
and everybody would
be better off.
And then my second
point, of my question,
I guess, is do you think
that the increase in wealth
disparity is related to the
influence of money on politics,
and how the accumulation
of wealth, which could then
be used to impact politics, is
itself an exacerbating cycle,
and that therefore,
the solution would
be to kind of
crowd fund politics
in some sense to
democratize it again?
JERRY KAPLAN: Well, I'm sure
Hal could probably do a better
job than I can, but I'm the
speaker, so on the first point
was relating to?
I can only remember
one thing at a time.
Productivity, yeah.
It's a complicated equation.
The automation makes
people more productive,
that means you
need fewer of them.
But it takes a certain amount
of time, it's like a cycle.
It's estimated at
10 to 15 years.
There's process re-engineering,
and the money, the new wealth
that is created goes
out into society,
and society then
creates new jobs, often
in different places.
So it's the lag that
creates the problem.
It puts people out of
work in the short run.
In the long run, it
creates more wealth
and generates a
lot more new jobs.
Your second point, sorry, didn't
get what-- Money in politics?
My opinion?
Absolutely.
It's completely ridiculous.
People look at Iran, and
say why this is terrible,
the Ayatollah has to approve
everybody who runs for office,
why would we have
a system like that?
Well, we have the
same system here.
If you can't get a very small
group of very wealthy people--
it's like 150 families, I think,
was in the New York Times--
to support you, you
can't run for office.
So that's a gate that's very
sadly has been put in place.
And my opinion is, you
call it crowd-funding,
but they used have
a check off box,
I don't even know if
they still have that
for presidential campaigns.
Absolutely.
We need to get the
money, you don't
have to get it out
of politics, you
have to have it
reduce its influence.
And it's an obvious reason
why the people who are getting
elected take the point of
view to do the things that
benefit the wealthy.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's thank
you again for coming
and we'll be signing
books in the back.